it's been a year since Russia's
President Vladimir Putin announced what
he called
the special military operation in
Ukraine leading to the largest war in
Europe since World War II
President Vladimir zielinski has led a
commemoration service in the capital
Kiev ceremony is also being held in
other cities across Ukraine to remember
the thousands of people who lost their
lives and the millions who've been
forced from their homes since the start
of the conflict let's bring in
altazira's Charles Trafford who's in
bravery to the east of Kiev Charles tell
us what happened there
it says when you join us as you say in
the town of Bravery it's about 15
kilometers behind me to the outskirts of
the capital Kiev and it's around about
100 kilometers in that direction to the
Belarus border where it's understood
that a couple of days into the war a
tank column a Russian tank column came
down this road and was trapped in the
town of bravery and heavily ambushed by
Ukrainian forces video appeared of this
that was released by the Ukrainian
military a few days into the war and
many military analysts will tell you
that it's a graphic indication of some
of the kind of failures that uh that
Russia had in the early stages of this
war the ukrainians tried basically to
take out both the lead vehicle and the
back vehicle in this Russian tank column
in a bid to try and trap the column
um
that didn't work it wasn't a hundred
percent successful but analysts are
still baffled to this day as to why
Russian forces would have used a main
archery a main road like this so exposed
to try and push into into Kiev without
for example the help of infantry to try
and push back any kind of Ambush and
that video that you're looking at there
was very much
set the tone if you like for the kind of
defeat that Russian forces suffered in
in their attempts to take control of
Kiev and of course it was under a month
later that Russian forces were forced to
withdraw back out of this area
meanwhile we know that there is heavy
fighting continuing on the Eastern front
lines in the Don bass region
specifically around that Flashpoint town
of bakboot where we understand that
they've been heavy casualties suffered
on both sides that fighting being like
go ongoing four months
um we heard from the Wagner group a
couple of days ago they announced that
they had got the ammunition that they've
been asking for so we understand that
those clashes are intensifying all the
time interestingly also Russian forces
claiming that they've taken a control of
a small town just to the north
attempting to surround it we know that
they've taken control of the Southern
Villages as well there's also a lot of
heavy fighting around avdievka in
Donetsk as well and Lee man as well
which is close to the lugansk regional
border where Donetsk and lugansk
actually meet this has been a flash
point Lee man was actually retaking
control of by the ukrainians in the late
Autumn this fighting an indication that
Russians are obviously trying to push
Ukrainian forces back now we've been
looking at the Battlefront since
Russia's Invasion a year ago today and
this is our report
on February the 24 2022 as the first
wave of Russian troops crossed the
border as Russian missiles Struck it
fast became clear that Vladimir Putin's
insistence that he would not invade
Ukraine had been a lie
it was a multi-pronged attack Russian
forces crossed from Belarus and advanced
towards cave there was a similar push in
the Northeast
and in the East towards Ukraine's Second
City kharkiv at the same time mainly
pro-russia separatist forces attacked
towns in ukrainian-controlled areas of
Donetsk and nugansk
the Ukrainian president not yet in his
trademark military fatigues called for
help
I had a conversation with U.S President
Joe Biden the U.S is starting to gather
International support
poor planning and brave Ukrainian
defense quickly scarfed Putin's
immediate plans to take give
Russian army columns were soon bogged
down and smashed
the enemy poorly calculated their
Communications in logistic needs and
their supply warehouses were across the
border this meant that after two days
they were stopped without fuel
ammunition and food and they lost the
effective management of their troops
on the 1st of April Ukraine announced it
had recaptured the entire region around
Kiev
dead civilians some with their hands
bound behind their backs were discovered
seemingly where they had been shot
Russia was accused of war crimes
the Russian army which Ukrainian
intelligence says had planned on taking
control of Kiev in three days had
suffered a historic and humiliating
defeat
in May after months of intense fighting
in the port city of mariopol the last
Romanian Ukrainian Fighters surrendered
at the azov style steel plant
but Ukraine by now is receiving what
would become tens of billions of dollars
worth of military aid
Autumn counter-offensive liberated tens
of thousands of square kilometers
including the city of Kirsten
preparations for the counter-offensive
started in April by June when we had
received Western weapons we were better
able to hit their supply lines command
centers and weapons and fuel Depots we
could also attack the reserved troops as
they approached the front line
but since December Ukrainian gains have
slowed to a virtual standstill
Russia has made small advances in
eastern donbass using what Ukrainian
forces say is wave after wave of
infantry soldiers and mercenaries from
the Wagner group
some of the heaviest fighting continues
around the town of bakmut where many of
the estimated 5 000 civilians Who Remain
there refuse to be evacuated
officials here in Kiev and their Western
allies are convinced that Russia is
about to launch what they describe as a
spring offensive more sophisticated
Weaponry such as tanks is on its way
from NATO countries but with no end in
sight to the fighting many are asking
just how long Ukraine's allies can fund
this war despite their leaders saying it
is a fight for democracy they cannot
lose Charles Stratford Al Jazeera Kiev
well the war has separated so many
families more than 8 million Ukrainian
refugees have fled to neighboring
countries most of them are women and
children Poland has welcomed the most
with around one and a half million
people settling there Germany is hosting
an estimated 1 million Ukrainian
refugees but like many countries it's
faced challenges especially in providing
proper housing and services the Czech
Republic took in around 500 000 people
it's one of 27 EU Nations where
ukrainians are allowed to live and work
for up to three years Italy Spain and
the UK are also supporting Ukrainian
refugees each has welcomed around 150
000 people
Antonio vittorino is the director
general of the International
Organization for migration he's with us
now live in Geneva Antonio what are the
iom's priorities right now in Ukraine
we focus above all in the fact that the
17.6 million people inside Ukraine are
in need of humanitarian assistance and
we do a periodic surveys among them and
we have come to the conclusion that the
highest demand from their side is cash
they need to have cash assistance to
conduct their daily lives medicine else
and psychosocial and mental support are
also extremely relevant and certainly we
still are fighting against the winter so
Sheltering people for the winter giving
them warm closes and eating
facilities is extremely important
because as you know the Sheltering of
the electric grid is raising the
difficulties of people to resist to the
very low temperatures in the field those
are indeed the priorities of assistance
that we have today
and I tell you do you that's the people
who are here who are internally
displaced you have any idea that how
many people have left Ukraine and how
many of those who did leave have
returned over the past year
yeah we think that uh eight million
people have left Ukraine to the
neighboring countries and in the last
year roughly there are still 5.5 million
this internally displaced people which
means people that live in a different
place than their place of origin inside
Ukraine and there are 5.5 million
returnees too of which 20 which means
roughly 1 million and above 1 million
have come from abroad but let me
emphasize one point even those who
return to their places of origin are in
need of humanitarian assistance 65
percent of the people that have returned
to their places of origin have seen
their houses destroyed or significantly
damaged and therefore they need shelter
they need food support they need water
they need electricity so they are in
need as any other internally displaced
people in spite of the fact that they
have returned to their places of origin
there seems to be a lot of speculation
to tell you that an escalation in
fighting is imminent what are the iom's
plans to deal with that especially uh if
Russia gains more territory given that
humanitarian needs are reportedly so
much greater in russian-held areas
let me be very clear on this point the
decision of the UN system of all the one
system is to stay and deliver and of
course the fate of the war is
unpredictable that's why we need
flexible funding flexible funding is
very important to allow us to adapt to
whatever might happen to any eventual
evolution of the war the challenge that
we have is to have access to the people
in it and that depends also on the
evolution of the fighting between the
two countries and we have a duty of care
of our staff of course but we have been
able to deliver a humanitarian support
to the people in the front line at high
risks so if there is a further
escalation of the war we will have to be
prepared to adapt to go on delivering
assistance and we have been procuring
and pre-positioning critical items of
support for for to deal with any
possible eventuality
Antonio vizarina director general of the
International Organization for migration
many thanks indeed the United Nations
General Assembly has voted
overwhelmingly in favor of a resolution
calling on Russia to withdraw from
Ukraine Moscow has faced criticism for
many for many member states over alleged
war crimes committed against civilians
in the early days of the war Natasha
Butler reports now from cherryheeve
the aftermath of a Russian attack in the
northern Ukrainian city of chernohev
last year on the ground bodies of
civilians they'd been queuing outside a
shop for bread when they were hit by
shells and Rockets 15 people were killed
dozens injured
so you were standing around here
Natasha narrowly escaped death that day
by taking cover by this wall she was in
the queue with her son and mother-in-law
she plays me a recording she made on her
phone
[Music]
we heard explosions near us it was very
close and then we saw lots of people
running everywhere
at the time of the attack chair naive
was a city under siege Russian forces
were surrounding it and shelled it
almost daily they destroyed Power and
Water Supplies evidence of what happened
is still visible nearly everywhere
this is where people were lining up for
bread that day it is right in the middle
of a residential area and what
prosecutors in the city say is that what
happened on that day is a war crime an
indiscriminate attack on civilians
[Music]
law enforcement agencies consider this a
war crime because the main victims were
civilians also a pre-trial investigation
found no evidence of Ukrainian military
hardware that could be a legitimate
Target weapons were used
indiscriminately
all this uh
Mark CL marks are the place
Place buildings make this information
Marina slobodianuk works with the rights
organization called Truth hounds that's
helping prosecutors to build a case it's
collated evidence and used open source
materials satellite imagery and social
media to reconstruct what happened her
team says it's traced the killings to a
Russian unit that was positioned on the
outskirts of the city we identified also
the command of this brigade
who
might be liable and responsible for this
very kind of attack
whether Oleg Korean or another officer
was responsible for the attack on the
bread Q might never be proved some
investigators say he's back in Russia
it's clear that building legal cases and
Prosecuting alleged war crimes is a
challenge but for some ukrainians
pursuing Justice is at least one way of
honoring the war's many victims
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera chernihiv
Ukraine
let's go live now to butcher some 30
kilometers west of Kiev Al jazeera's
hotter Abdel Hamid joins us from there
put your Hoda one of the first places
where we saw Russian atrocities against
Ukrainian civilians how does it feel a
year later
while certain time we were standing here
at one of the cemeteries on the
outskirts of bucha just a short while
ago there was a ceremony to commemorate
soldiers who are dying on the front line
but also those who lost their lives
during the Russian occupation of this
area it started actually on the 27th of
February on this day last year on the
24th of February Russian paratroopers
were Landing in an airport not very far
from here hostel Mill about 10 minute
drive from butcher but it's only three
days later that the tanks actually
arrived here and they stayed more until
the 31st of March now when they pull out
the Ukraine and actually the world
discovered the scale of what happened in
butcher if you remember those pictures
of bodies strewn on the ground
abandoned there some of of them were
found with they were they had been
blindfolded and executed Point Blank
there were Mass Graves that were
discovered in total about
450 bodies and out of those at least a
third showing signs of tortures butcher
came to really represent the horrors of
Russia's occupation and it's from here
really that Ukraine started building up
its war crimes uh filed Buddha butcher
chapter being a very big and extensive
one simply because when they arrived
here everything was so fresh and
everything was so evident everywhere I
remember coming here in the weeks after
the liberation of Butcher and bodies
were still being exiled we followed an
investigation team throughout the day
and they were really going in side roads
they were receiving phone calls of
people returning to their homes and
finding things graves in their backyards
it was a continuous exhumation one after
the other and at the morgue the bodies
were just piling up and some of the
families were not here the mothers and
the children who had gone Westward maybe
crossed into Poland so they had to come
back to recognize these bodies before
they could be worried they're buried so
it was certainly a very dark chapter for
abucha and I think it's a chapter from
which this town has still not recovered
as the full scale and the Reconstruction
of the horrors that happened here is
ongoing
how do many things indeed Abdul Hamid
they're live in butcher west of Kiev
China has released its own 12 point
proposal to end the conflict in Ukraine
following talks between top Diplomat
Wang Yi and Russia's President Vladimir
Putin we're going to take a closer look
at that proposal now Beijing is calling
for an end to Western sanctions on
Russia and has urged Moscow and Kiev to
hold peace talks the plan calls for the
establishment of humanitarian corridors
for civilians as well as steps to ensure
that grain can be safely exported from
the region it also warns against the use
of nuclear weapons in the conflict as
well as attacks on nuclear power plants
shortly we'll get reaction to the plan
from Zain basavi here in Kiev but first
let's cross to Katrina u in Beijing
Katrina can China be a reliable mediator
in this conflict
well Beijing believes so it says that
unlike the us or other Western European
countries it's not trying to change
Russia or Ukraine it says it's a neutral
party that's only interested in ceasing
hostilities and doing this via dialogue
not through sanctions or through arming
Ukraine now that's what Beijing says but
its actions point in a very different
direction China has so far failed to
condemn Russia's invasion of Ukraine and
repeatedly we've seen Beijing tout it's
no limits Rock Solid friendship with
Russia and over the past year trade
between the two countries has also
sought not only that we've had uh
president Xi Jinping speak to Vladimir
Putin at least three times in this past
year we know that the two are two
personal friends and he's also planning
to visit Moscow later this year and
conversely we have not had as far as we
know any effort on XI jinpinga's part to
reach out to zelenski now the US says
that China's support of Russia could be
going even further that Beijing is
planning or considering sending weapons
to Russia for use in its war machine but
so far this is something that Beijing
denies
Katrina many thanks indeed let's bring
in Zane bus Ravi then who's also here in
Kiev president zielinski has spoken uh
Zayn what did he have to say what's his
reaction to this Chinese plan
well the Ukrainian president as well as
the foreign Ministry have both said that
they have communicated with China about
the plan they're aware of this proposal
and they say that this is a positive
development that China getting involved
that the idea of dialogue all of these
things are positive indicators now this
is very different from the reaction that
Ukraine has had to other allies of
Russia they are staunchly critical of of
any Russian allies or anyone even
sympathetic to Russia even the French
leaders have gotten in trouble for
trying to strike a bit of a balance but
when it comes to this the ukrainians I
think recognize that you cannot isolate
or not communicate with such a strong
country so they have welcomed it as a
positive but it's difficult to see how
Ukraine and Russia how they can find a
middle ground when Ukraine has said very
clearly that it is a red line for them
any territorial compromise they want
donbass but it is really difficult to
see how China can strike any dialogue
with that as a red line for Ukraine's
government
and saying what are people there saying
about this one year anniversary
well it has been a very hard year for
the Ukrainian people
um we're at a church and a Services
happening at churches all over uh the
country today to Mark a year of War a
year of loss of life
um just behind me we were inside the
monastery at the St Michael's Monastery
and people there lighting candles
praying for The Departed for those
killed in this uh in this war people
praying for loved ones at the front line
we saw a troop of soldiers go in and uh
offer prayers and then presumably head
back out to their post possibly headed
to fighting in the East so people are
really using this as a as a moment of
reflection something interesting we
heard from people uh just yesterday
people are sharing their photographs and
their memories of the beginning of the
war the before and after of the
destruction but they've also been
marking the 23rd of February as the day
that was the last day of peace sharing
pictures of themselves on the last day
of peace before this very long war and
they hope that their leaders are right
when they say that the spring will bring
decisive battles and that the war will
be over this year that is something not
just the intelligence Services of
Ukraine or the government is talking
about that's something people are
talking about as well they want to
return to civilian life and they Echo
their leaders voices when they say that
it will end on their terms the peace
will come when ukrainians are all
returned to Ukraine when the Ukrainian
territory is returned into Ukrainian
hands and something we keep hearing from
people is that Russia may have started
this war but Ukraine will end it and it
will end on Ukrainian terms
Zane many thanks indeed same bus Ravi
there in central cave that's all from
Ukraine's capital for the moment let's
get you back to rob in Doha
Adrian thanks we're going to go to Osama
bin Javed now in Moscow we're going to
get a reaction to China's peace proposal
um Osama obviously this is the the
central focus at the moment it's
certainly coming out of Beijing I always
Russia feeling about this proposal from
China
well this is a proposal that Russia has
welcomed ahead of it being launched
saying that China can prove its role to
make sure that the conflict does not
escalate as the Western countries point
fingers towards China being close to
Russia Russia has said that it is
essentially the United States and its
Western Partners who are Fanning the
Flames of War by providing weapons to
Kiev so it is going to be interesting to
see how exactly uh Russia reacts to this
so far no official reactions since
president Xi Jinping outlined this plan
but we all know that this is something
that was essentially hand delivered to
President Vladimir Putin by China's top
Diplomat from the Chinese president so
Russia has welcomed it but as the
anniversary is today we've heard from
the Russian Deputy chairman of the
National Security Council saying that
this is a war which is going to continue
until Russia wins it those assertions by
the United States that it is Russia who
should end the war he called them lies
and Dmitry Medvedev says that Russia
will continue to pursue denotsification
as he likes to call it of Ukraine even
if it has to the go to the border with
Poland we've been talking a lot over the
last few minutes about the impact that
this war has had on Ukraine but clearly
of course it's having an impact in
Russia as well we're seeing Russian
soldiers dying we're seeing people in
Russia who have are watching shops and
large Brands pulling out of their
country how are people in Russia feeling
about this conflict a year on
well in the past year there were initial
concerns about the people because
essentially ukrainians are very much
tied into the society with Russia we
people here have family members they
have very deep connections with Ukraine
uh but in the last year this has been
presented as a war which was inevitable
for Russia President Vladimir Putin has
told his people that this is a war but
Russia had to go to because it's not
just fighting Ukraine it's fighting for
its territorial Integrity because there
was an amassing of uh Western Weaponry
including some nuclear uh Arsenal that
was talked about coming into Ukraine so
this is something where the Russians
people in the last year have come closer
to they can relate to it they think that
this is an inevitable War which their
country had to fight obviously they have
feel they have felt the impact of this
on the everyday life but by and large
Russia continues to carry on we've heard
from President Vladimir Putin saying the
West has failed to defeat them
militarily break their economy or
isolate them internationally and this is
something that resonates with the
Russian people because even fast food
chains including McDonald's and
Starbucks are all operating but with
different names and Russian owners Osama
Benjamin to talk to us from Moscow Osama
thank you very much indeed
I'm a colleague Adrian Finnegan's going
to be back in half an hour with our
special coverage of the Ukraine conflict
our year into the war
now we're marking the first anniversary
with newsos live from Kiev at 11 GMT and
1600 GMT